So the barrier algorithm is going to work like this. When
a thread arrives at a barrier, what it is going to
do is, it is decrement the count exactly like, like
in the counting barrier. It's going to decrement the count. But after
it, its decrements the count, what it is going to do
is, it's going to Spin on Sense reversal. Remember that, you
know the sense flag is going to be True for. This
barrier and once everybody has progressed to the next barrier the,
the sense flag will become false. And therefore, let's say
that we are executing the, the true barrier. In other words
all the threads are executing some right here. The sense flag
is true, and so if T1 comes along it decrements the
count and it's not going to worry about whether the count
has become zero or no. All that it is going to read
on, is for the sense to reverse. So it's, it's saying
well my sense is we are on the true value here
I'll stay here until the sense becomes false. I'll
know then that, that we've moved on to the next
value point. That's the idea behind behind what all the
processors will do except the last one. What did the
last one do? Well, you guessed it. The last one,
in addition to resetting the count to N, which was
happening in the counting barrier, it was also going to reverse
the sense flag. So, last processor comes along and finds
that the count has become zero, it'll reset it to N.
No problem with that. And then it is going to reverse the
sense flag. It used to be True here, and it's going to
reset it to False. And all the other guys are waiting on
the sense reversal. So decrementing the count itself by chaining the,
the count value, that doesn't do anything to these threads. Only
when the sense flag is reversed, all these guys come out
of the spindle and they can go on. So you can see
now that we ha, have only one spinning
episode per critical section or one spinning episode per
Barrier. What we're doing is we decrement the count
and spin on sense reversal, last guy decrements the
count. When count goes to zero, resets it to
N. And then it is going to reverse the sense.
And that is the signal for all the reading
processes to say well we can now go on
to the next phase of the computation. So we've gotten
rid of one of the spinning episodes that used to
be there in the pure counting version of the centralized
barrier. One of the centralized barrier is simple and intuitive
as to what's going on and of course with the
sense reversing barrier we got rid of two spinning episodes
and got it down to to one. All of these
are good things. But the problem is, that you have a
si, shared variable for all the processors. And
so if you have a large scale. multi-processor. And
if you're running large-scale scientific applications with lots of
parallel threads and they have to do a barrier,
causes a lot of contention on the interconnection
network. Because of this hot spot for this shared
variable. And remember what our good friend Chuck Thacker
said, less sharing means the multi-processor is more scalable.
And that is something that we want to carry forward in
thinking about how to get rid of this sharing that
is happening among the large number of processes in order
to build a more scalable version of a various synchronization algorithm.